and they launched Apple TV plus so I
guess putting the plus on it means we're
gonna be charging you in there when it's
virtual I mean that's pretty interesting
you don't have to buy the box anymore
that's a very uh napple thing that to me
was interesting you can get it on your
Roku or wherever yeah that's so you're
paying for it yeah you're paying for it
that's fine
and they're gonna go to this very Apple
you're gonna go up against Netflix and
Amazon Prime
yeah but they had this big Oprah
announcement and I was like is she
bringing her show back or whatever and
she's doing two documentaries or
something like what did they back up the
brakes truck for for her is that 100
million you they I don't think we know
very much about this service yet we
don't know what it cost we don't know
how much they're spending on it we don't
know how committed they are to it we
don't know what the breadth of content
is gonna be so they rolled out Oprah
that's cool I mean they've got what 250
billion dollars in the bank something
crazy yeah
so they give it up with Netflix we just
don't know if they're they just don't
want anybody to do anything that's adult
yeah that's fine
sir no Game of Thrones no Breaking Bad
no Sopranos no I don't know we do we
know they're billing that since Oreo
about that's what they that's what the
trades and Hollywood have been saying is
that they don't want they want
everything family-friendly and it's like
I think that train has left the station
but now I'm looking at it I mean have
they ever been on the App Store hasn't
come on well I mean you can use HP oh--
through the Gap store at Netflix yeah
I'm just saying there's like a lot of
non family-friendly stuff in the Apple
ecosystem I guess if it has the Apple
name at the beginning they don't want
what follows to include sex or violence
that's fair they are actually making
this content whereas that possible
deniability if they're carrying isn't he
seems to have done pretty well with this
right so Deadpool was is racy right yeah
I mean they have the Marvel stuff but I
personally don't think that's a problem
I think the question is just we don't
know how committed to what they are we
don't know how good the bundle is gonna
be yeah but they can make it viable a
fake there's the thing where you can
just spend money until it works the
interesting thing though is like if I
was watching some Camille we watch like
the stand-up comedians on Netflix these
comedians are saying things that Apple
would never be able to stand behind
anything Netflix I think would have a
hard time standing behind isolated clips
from
Amy Schumer or Chris Rock like back in
the day now and I don't know how Apple
is gonna do anything interesting with
the service or the Apple news is gonna
fail I think Apple TV plus is gonna fail
Apple music is a huge success right
here's the thing it I don't know if it's
gonna fail seems like it very well could
but I don't even know if it's for the
reason that you're outlining like what
who-who under 30 is watching TV on a TV
screen anymore no that is that is not
really the thing right so the same way
that like Apple News plus feels like a
you know an announcement for a baby
boomers like in it kind of feels like
the same thing for Apple TV plus I mean
granted I'll probably subscribe and try
it out but I'm an old person so to
bundle this it's now getting ridiculous
they need to have it there a bowl prime
prime that's what needs to comes a prime
because it's now 10 bucks for News ten
bucks for music we'll assume TVs gonna
be 10 bucks the arcade is gonna be 10
bucks baby I don't know they didn't
answer pricing for that Apple care I
spend 10 bucks on my Tutera buy family
plan Apple care is like 5 bucks a month
per phone so if you have two phones in
your house is another 10 bucks this 60
bucks a month now we're looking at $700
a year bundle for everything cut it in
half 350 is that a good deal for all of
that it depends if that's your bundle I
mean I think people are angsty about I
got my Netflix I got my Hulu I got this
it's like well at some point there's
gonna be a bunch of these bundles and
you're gonna pick the two or three that
you want and go with them so yeah I'm
less bearish on the Apple Plus even
given that we don't really know what it
is but you know we'll see and eventually
a bundle I think the most interesting
thing was the Apple car which